I'm going to use Flexbox to create
this layout, and then I'm going to
give you a design mock that I want
you to provide the styles for.
I've got my markup for the HTML here.
The first thing I need to do is set
up Flexbox on my container element.
I need to add display flex.
And flex-wrap, wrap.
Looking at my layout I can see
that some things are out of order.
For example this dark blue box,
is not in the same place down here.
And I want to make sure they are.
Are.
So in addition to setting
the width of each element,
I need to remember to set the order.
To make things a bit easier for
myself, I've added the styles in
the order that the elements appear.
The header element is the first element,
and it spans the whole width.
So I'll set the width to 100 and
order to one.
Red and orange are next.
Each looks to be about 50%
of the view point width.
So I'll set width equals 50% and
order to two and three respectively.
In this design, the footer is next at
100% width, and order equals four.
The next line is light blue,
dark blue, and green.
Light blue and green,
each looks like they are about 20% wide.
Dark blue looks like
it's about 60% wide.
So, I'll set order to five, six, and
seven on each of those
elements respectively.
Let's compare this to our sample.
Looks about right to me.
Let's see how you do.